so one of the my strategies pig in terms
of you know getting the money back as we
put we you know because a quote no
budget film but there's still a decent
amount of money in there and and I you
know been doing this a long time and I
know how hard it is to make really good
movie and while we've set out to make a
great movie and we've set out to make an
art film and which is a difficult kind
of movie to sell it's not a you know
it's not doesn't have a kind of built-in
genre audience and that kind of thing
you know my strategy is to say how can I
sell this movie even if it's not a good
movie even if we don't end up making a
good movie you know we still need to get
our money back we're raising a little
bit of money for finishing funds and I
don't want to rely on you know the fact
that we make a great movie that that's
the only way and even when you do make a
great movie doesn't mean your money back
so I've come up with this you know idea
or not you know not it's not a theory
it's just the kind of reality that I'm
starting to realize that there's an
audience for your movie no matter how
good your movie is there you know
Studios know this because they make a
lot of bad movies and they still sell a
lot of tickets but it's harder i think
for independent filmmakers who are
making you know kind of art films when
they don't get into sundance they don't
they don't achieve these certain kind of
goals they feel like well there's no one
out there that will like their film but
they're thinking of in terms of the
audience and in these you know broad
categories like art house audience well
that's maybe true and arthouse audience
needs to see that you were in these
festivals needs to see a certain awards
and whatever but that doesn't mean that
there's not some other audience that
that won't you know that won't
appreciate what you've done so kind of
what job was saying about you know
digging deeper in terms of who that who
those audiences are you know we've
really made a point of thinking about
you know who's going to like our film
you know who is it who is it talking to
what other films are similar ours that
people have liked that built you know
kind of a rabid fan base and we really
had to dig into that you know we are
film is a mystery you know perhaps
there's you know their their communities
around mysteries that that we haven't
you know we don't need
we haven't explored yet that we can kind
of dig into the film is kind of a puzzle
distance I mean it natively it's a
puzzle it it's kind of a mind game film
so we thought you know there's people
who play games or like puzzles these
might be people who like the film so
we're developing games and puzzles that
put on online before there's ever a film
and we're presenting a kind of I guess
it's our brand we're kind of presenting
a look or whatever that city and says
this is this is not we're not making
this easy for you you know you go to our
website and there's no the name of the
film was done on the website it's we've
got these symbols that are up that that
you have to kind of figure out I mean
it's not that hard to figure out but you
have to kind of figure out and
everything is you know the design of
this kind of brand is that you have to
kind of figure it out and we have these
little little kind of marketing games
and things like we have a character in
the film the films about a guy wakes up
in the middle of desert and he his hands
were tied behind his back and he has a
black hood on his head he doesn't have
any idea how he got there who he is and
when he finally gets his hands untied he
pulls out a piece of paper that has this
name Manny elder written on it he
doesn't know if he's Manning elder or if
there's a guy that was trying to make me
kill him was Manny elder or what but so
we came up with this idea that we would
make these little business cards that
say Manny elder on it and that's all
they say I've got him in my pocket and
basically make 10,000 of these and
spread them all over the country with
giving boxes of them to friends and just
put these little mini elder cards around
and it's what I call a long con this is
like a this is this is a an idea that
may not bear any fruit at all but it
doesn't really cost anything it's kind
of fun to do and so you know I don't
know two out of a hundred pick up this
card and maybe go what is this doesn't
have anything else written on it and
maybe they go home and maybe they look
it up and then we start planting this
information on the on the internet fake
meny elder information it's kind of
weird and maybe doesn't quite add up and
and it just starts to kind of create
something around you know this one
component of our film and we feel like
the people that do that though the
people that don't just toss that card
actually go do that work we're going to
like the movie because of the kind of
movie it is and what you know what's
going on in that film that's our
audience I mean we think the people that
you know want to play these puzzles and
games like that or people are going to
enjoy our film because it is a puzzle a
lot a lot of people won't like the film
because it it's a puzzle because it's
hard to understand what's going on or
whatever and so you know those people if
they don't like the website it's not
such a horrible thing because that maybe
it wasn't the right film for them anyway
but we kind of feel like these other
folks will kind of get into it and it's
just a kind of a way to kind of pull
these people out from under the rocks
you know and we have a bunch of these
kinds of ideas where there you're trying
to find a certain person who's
interested in discovering interested in
kind of doing the extra research or
figuring out something that's out
spoon-fed to them and it's just a just a
kind of beginning of a process of
thinking about who our audiences are and
how we might be able to engage them in
it in an interesting way and it's again
it's fun for us to do that to kind of
come up with these ideas